Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Robin: "A FOOL HATH SAID IN
HIS HEART, 'THERE IS NO GOD.'"
Tyra: ROBIN TRIED TO FORCE
HER RELIGION ON ELYSE.
Robin: THAT MADE ME
THINK OF YOU.
Elyse: THAT WAS
A REALLY FORWARD THING TO DO.
Ebony: THE COMPETITION...
Tyra: AND EBONY TRIED
TO CONCEAL TYRA MAIL
FROM THE GROUP.
Robin: THOSE DEMONS THAT
YOU HAVE WITHIN YOURSELF
ARE GOING TO COME OUT.
Ebony: WELL, ROBIN,
I'M SORRY.
THIS IS A MODEL COMPETITION.
Tyra: THE GIRLS PUT
THEIR SEXUALITY ON THE LINE.
Katie: THE SEX APPEAL
AND STUFF--THAT'S JUST ME.
Tyra: KATIE'S OVERT
SENSUALITY HURT HER,
AND SHE WAS THE ONE
ASKED TO LEAVE.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: WITH KATIE
BEING ELIMINATED,
IT'S GONNA BE WEIRD.
THAT IS ONE PERSON
I DID NOT EXPECT TO GO.
DID YOU?
LAST JUDGMENT DAY
IT WAS REALLY HARD ON ME
BECAUSE I FELT LIKE
I COULDN'T GIVE IT MY BEST.
Tyra: ADRIANNE,
THAT RUNWAY WALK, GIRL--
WERE YOU PRESENT?
Adrianne: YES, MA'AM.
I MEAN, THE REALITY
HAS FINALLY HIT ME THAT
THERE IS GONNA BE ELIMINATIONS.
I WANTED TO QUIT SMOKING,
BUT TODAY WAS
REALLY NERVE-RACKING.
Elyse: IT SEEMS THAT ADRIANNE
IS TAKING THE COMPETITION
A LITTLE BIT TOO SERIOUSLY,
SO I'M GETTING A CERTAIN
JUST STRESSFUL VIBE FROM HER.
Adrianne: THERE'S MONEY ISSUES
IN MY FAMILY,
AND THAT'S WHY
I REALLY, REALLY NEED THIS.
Nicole: OKAY, WAIT,
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA LIKE THIS.
Giselle: HOW CUTE IS THAT?
Adrianne: WHAT'S HIS NAME AGAIN?
Nicole: CORY.
Giselle: SO YOUR BOYFRIEND'S,
LIKE, FAMOUS?
Adrianne: YEAH.
Nicole: YEAH, HE'S FAMOUS
IN HIS OWN WORLD.
Adrianne: SHE DATES
A FAMOUS MAN.
Nicole: MY BOYFRIEND--
HIS NAME'S CORY.
HE RIDES BMX PROFESSIONALLY.
WE'RE SO CLOSE, AND WE'RE
ALWAYS TOGETHER, BUT NOW I'M 22.
I NEED TO LEARN
A LITTLE BIT OF INDEPENDENCE,
YOU KNOW, AND THIS IS IT.
(beep)
Nicole: HEY, HONEY. IT'S ME.
HEY, BABY DOLL, IT'S ME.
- (beep)
- Nicole: HEY, IT'S ME.
BABE, IT'S ME.
HEY, PUMPKIN, IT'S ME.
IT'S REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY, REALLY HARD.
REALLY HARD.
I ALMOST LOST IT A COUPLE TIMES,
AND I WANNA CRY SOMETIMES,
BUT I NEED TO BE OKAY.
♪♪♪
Tyra: BEAUTY IN REAL LIFE
AND BEAUTY IN
THE MODELING INDUSTRY ARE
TWO TOTALLY DIFFERENT THINGS,
AND IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO TRANSFORM THE GIRLS
FROM NORMAL, EVERYDAY
PRETTY GIRLS ON THE STREET
TO HIGH FASHION MODELS.
- HELLO, EVERYBODY.
- Women: HI.
Tyra: SO TODAY
AS YOU GUYS CAN SEE,
YOU'RE AT THE LéPINE SALON.
YOU GUYS ARE ALREADY FIERCE,
BUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU...
- (snapping fingers)
- FIERCE.
AND WE HAVE JAY MANUEL HERE,
WHO IS MY PERSONAL
MAKEUP ARTIST.
Jay: HEY.
Tyra: AND HE'S GONNA BE
DOING YOUR FACES.
AND THIS IS KIM LéPINE.
SHE'S THE OWNER OF THE SALON,
AND HER TEAM IS GONNA GIVE YOU
HAIR TRANSFORMATIONS.
NO ONE WILL WALK OUT LOOKING
LIKE WHAT THEY WALKED IN.
ALL RIGHT? BE BRAVE.
I WANNA START WITH ELYSE.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU A PIXIE.
A LITTLE BIT, LIKE,
REALLY CHOPPED AND CUTE,
KIND OF ELFISH.
SHANNON, I WANNA
BLEACH YOU OUT MORE.
I WANNA JUST BRIGHTEN YOU UP.
WE MIGHT EVEN ADD A LITTLE BIT
MORE HAIR EXTENSIONS
TO THICKEN YOU UP.
ADRIANNE, I THINK WE
NEED TO GIVE HER A HAIR WEAVE,
SEW IN SOME LOCKS,
MAKE HER VERY SEXY.
Adrianne: I WAS SO EXCITED
BECAUSE FOR SO MANY YEARS
I'VE WANTED TO DO THIS,
BUT I JUST SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
THE FUNDS.
Tyra: ROBIN, I THINK
YOUR HAIR IS WAY TOO DARK
FOR YOUR SKIN TONE,
SO WE'RE GONNA LIGHTEN YOU UP.
Robin: MY HAIR WAS JET BLACK.
IT WAS NOTHING WRONG
WITH IT BEING JET BLACK.
Tyra: KESSE, YOUR HAIR IS ALSO
TOO DARK FOR YOUR SKIN TONE,
SO WE'RE GONNA LIGHTEN YOU UP,
AND WE'RE ALSO GONNA GIVE YOU
OLD TYRA BANKS HAIR FROM 1992.
LONG, THICK,
NICE HAIR EXTENSIONS.
NICOLE, WE'RE GOING TO
STRAIGHTEN YOUR HAIR.
Nicole: I WAS KINDA IFFY
ABOUT THE HAIR
BECAUSE I'M JUST NOT INTERESTED
IN STRAIGHTENING IT.
Tyra: EBONY, THIS LITTLE
PIECE OF HAIR RIGHT HERE--
THAT EXTRA LITTLE THING--GONE.
- Jay: GONE.
- Ebony: WORK ME.
Tyra: AND GISELLE.
GISELLE,
WHAT CAN WE DO WITH GISELLE?
Giselle: I DON'T KNOW,
I WAS LIKE, OKAY, WELL,
HOW COME MINE'S NOT
ALL FIGURED OUT?
Kim: SHE NEEDS
TO HAVE COLOR, AND I THINK
ALL THAT STRAGGLY THING--
SOME OF THAT HAS TO GO.
- Tyra: Y'ALL EXCITED?
- Women: YEAH!
Tyra: I CANNOT WAIT TO SEE
WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA LOOK LIKE.
- BYE, Y'ALL!
- Women: BYE!
Giselle: NICOLE JUST PAID,
LIKE, $1,500
FOR HER HAIR EXTENSIONS
THAT SHE HAS IN HER HAIR,
AND SHE DIDN'T WANT THOSE
TO BE REMOVED AT ALL.
Jay: WHETHER YOU LIKE IT
OR NOT,
YOU NEED TO DO
WHAT'S GOOD FOR YOUR CAREER,
NOT FOR WHAT NECESSARILY
YOU LIKE.
Elyse: ALMOST ALL THE GIRLS
WERE REALLY NERVOUS WHEN
THEY STARTED DOING THE HAIRCUTS
AND TALKING ABOUT THE DYE JOBS.
I ESPECIALLY NOTICED ROBIN
BLANCHING AT THE IDEA
OF DYEING HER HAIR
FROM BLACK TO BROWN.
Jay: DON'T LOOK SO SAD.
MODELS ARE CANVASES.
Robin: YEAH, I KNOW.
Jay: THEY'RE CANVASES,
AND THEY'RE ALSO CHAMELEONS.
Jay: NO, YOU DON'T.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: I WOULD HAVE TO SAY
EVERY GIRL EXCEPT ME
SEEMED VERY NERVOUS
AND DIDN'T WANNA
GET THEIR HAIR CUT.
Nicole: IF I'M OUT FOR THE JOB,
AND THEY WANT ME
TO DO SOMETHING,
I WILL MOST DEFINITELY DO THAT,
AND IN THIS SITUATION,
I'M JUST WORRIED,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW FAR
I'M GONNA MAKE IT, YOU KNOW.
Adrianne: NICOLE COMPLAINED
TO THE POINT
WHERE THEY WOULDN'T CUT OFF
AS MUCH AS THEY WOULD LIKE.
THEREFORE, SHE GOT WHAT
SHE WANTED INSTEAD OF WHAT
THEY WERE GONNA GIVE.
Woman: OKAY.
THERE YOU GO, SEXPOT.
Nicole: IT'S A SHOCK RIGHT NOW,
THOUGH.
I NEED TO GET USED TO IT.
IT'S A REALLY BIG SHOCK.
Giselle: SO YOU DON'T THINK
MY HAIR SHOULD BE ONE LENGTH.
- Man: NO.
- Adrianne: GISELLE CRIED.
GISELLE WHINED.
GISELLE MOANED.
GISELLE GROANED.
Giselle: IT'S SO SHORT.
I'M JUST USED TO THE WAY
I HAD MY HAIR,
SO I'M KIND OF
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LENGTH.
ELYSE'S MAKEOVER WAS AWESOME.
Man: ALL RIGHT, ELYSE,
YOU'RE ALL DONE.
Elyse: THANK YOU.
I REALLY LIKED MY HAIRCUT,
BUT I WAS A LITTLE BIT
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
WITH THE HAIR COLOR.
I'LL PROBABLY DYE IT BACK,
BUT IT'S FINE FOR NOW.
Ebony: IT WAS REALLY
JUST FRUSTRATING.
THE PEOPLE DID NOT HAVE
THE CORRECT CLIPPERS.
EVERYBODY BASICALLY SAT
AND THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
Woman: SHOULD WE LEAVE
A LITTLE TUFT?
Ebony: I DIDN'T EVEN LIKE
THE WAY THE WOMAN
WAS CUTTING MY HAIR
AND THE WAY THEY WERE HAVING
A CONVERSATION IN FRONT OF ME.
Woman #2: SHOULD WE
WRITE HER NAME?
Ebony: HEY, NOT EVERYBODY
CAN CUT YOUR HAIR,
AND YOU CAN ALWAYS GROW IT BACK,
SO, YOU KNOW,
I PLAN ON DOING THAT.
ALL RIGHT.
Woman: HAVE FUN
WITH YOUR HAIRCUT, THOUGH.
Shannon: I NEEDED MY HAIR
HIGHLIGHTED ANYWAY,
SO I WAS REALLY EXCITED.
Kesse: OH!
I KNEW I NEEDED A NEW LOOK,
SO I'M SO PLEASED
WITH THE OUTCOME.
Adrianne: I FEEL STUPID
BECAUSE I'M, LIKE,
THE TOMBOY OUT OF THE GIRLS,
AND I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S GOING ON.
WELL, THE WHOLE PROCESS
WITH THE WEAVE WAS VERY LONG
AND PRETTY PAINFUL,
BUT I DON'T LIKE TO SHOW ANYBODY
I'M GOING THROUGH PAIN,
SO I DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
IT WAS DEFINITELY WORTH IT,
YOU KNOW?
I LOOK
A MILLION TIMES DIFFERENT.
Robin: I'M TRYING TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYTHING IN HERE
ABOUT CHANGE.
Ebony: ROBIN'S ALWAYS,
YOU KNOW, SHE'S ALWAYS TALKED
ABOUT SHE'S FOR CHANGE.
YOU KNOW, AT THE SAME TIME,
SHE'S VERY DIVA-ISH.
Robin: A DIVA IS NOT
A BAD THING.
I THINK THAT A DIVA IS A LADY.
NOW HOW LIGHT
ARE WE TALKIN' ABOUT?
Woman: NO, A LITTLE-- A LITTLE
DARKER THAN YOUR ROB.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE BLONDE.
Giselle: ROBIN'S BEEN FRUSTRATED
WITH HER WHOLE HAIR SITUATION.
SHE DIDN'T WANNA
LIGHTEN IT UP AT ALL.
Adrianne: ROBIN WAS VERY SCARED
TO TAKE HER OLD WEAVE OUT,
BECAUSE SHE WANTED EVERYBODY
TO THINK IT WAS NATURAL,
BUT IT WASN'T.
Robin: I DON'T FEEL THAT, UM,
THIS COLOR IS RIGHT FOR ME.
IT'S KINDA LIKE JUST HAVING,
LIKE, HAIR COLOR
FROM H-E-DOUBLE HOCKEY STICKS.
Giselle: I'M PRETTY SURE
SHE HAS TO BE FRUSTRATED
ABOUT THAT, YOU KNOW? YEAH.
Elyse: YOU DO LOOK LIKE
A DIFFERENT PERSON.
Robin: GIRL, I KNOW.
Jay: TODAY'S LESSON IS
GOING TO BE ABOUT ESTABLISHING
A LOOK FOR YOURSELVES.
I'M GOING TO TRAIN YOU TO APPLY
TWO KINDS OF MAKEUP
USING REVLON--
ONE FOR DAY AND ONE FOR NIGHT.
REMEMBER EVERYTHING
I'M TEACHING YOU,
BECAUSE YOU WILL BE TESTED
ON IT.
Giselle: YEAH.
Jay: IF YOU'RE PUTTING IT
ON YOURSELF,
YOU'RE GONNA LOOK
DOWN YOUR NOSE,
AND THEN YOU'RE GONNA PRESS IT
IN THE CORNERS.
Elyse: THE FALSE EYELASHES--
I PROBABLY WON'T BE VERY GOOD
AT DOING THAT.
Jay: NEVER, EVER,
EVER MATCH YOUR EYE SHADOW
TO YOUR GOWN.
REALLY IMPORTANT THING IS
TO ALWAYS MOISTURIZE YOUR SKIN
UNDERNEATH MAKEUP.
Ebony: JAY MANUEL
IS ABSOLUTELY EXCELLENT,
ESPECIALLY SKIN CARE,
WHICH IS ONE OF MY ISSUES.
Jay: IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
DOING REVLON CONTRACTS,
YOU REALLY NEED TO HAVE
YOUR SKIN ON POINT.
Ebony: I AM MAKEUP ARTIST,
YOU KNOW,
BUT I'M ALSO
VERY NEW TO THE GAME.
Jay: OH, THAT'S GREAT.
SO YOU'VE PICKED UP
SOME TECHNIQUES.
THE MAKEUP ARTIST
IS YOUR LAST FRONT TO THE WORLD,
SO YOU NEVER WANNA
PISS THEM OFF,
'CAUSE THEY'LL MESS YOU UP.
- Shannon: WELL, THANKS.
- Jay: YOU'RE WELCOME.
Ebony: THANK YOU.
Adrianne: WHOO!
IT MAKES US LOOK HOT.
WHOO!
Elyse: THAT NIGHT
A COUPLE OF THE GIRLS
DIDN'T LIKE THEIR MAKEOVERS
FROM THE SALON.
- IT IS UNEVEN.
- Ebony: YEAH.
Elyse: THEY MESSED UP
SHAVING YOUR HEAD THAT BAD?
Ebony: IT IS VERY UPSETTING
TO AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMAN
TO GO INTO A SALON
AND A PERSON
TO DO HER HAIR INCORRECTLY.
IT'S VERY INAPPROPRIATE.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME.
Elyse: EBONY--SHE JUST GETS
GOING AND CANNOT STOP,
AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT WEIRD.
Ebony: A PERSON COULD
BE VIOLENT.
I COULD HAVE BEEN CRAZY
UP IN THERE, BUT OF COURSE
IT'S NOT MY PERSONALITY.
THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN MAN
THEY HAD THERE WAS THERE
FOR PIECES.
HE WASN'T THERE FOR THAT.
THAT WASN'T HIS TECHNIQUE
IN HIS JOB.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE ONE PERSON THERE
TO TRAIN TO DO EVERYTHING.
THE SALON WAS BEAUTIFUL.
THE MAKEUP WAS FABULOUS.
THE PEOPLE WERE GREAT.
Robin: THAT'S MESSED UP.
Ebony: IT'S MESSED UP!
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I MEAN, TYRA WOULD NOT
HAVE THIS.
Robin: WAIT A MINUTE,
GIRL, WAIT.
DO IT ONE MORE TIME.
GIRL, IT'S ALL MESSED UP.
Ebony: THIS IS NOT A STYLE.
THIS IS HORRIBLE!
GOD, IT'S RIDICULOUS.
I AM CONFUSED!
Shannon: OH, MY WORD!
YOU GUYS ARE MEAN.
Robin: WE KNOW YOU BLACK,
I'M BLACK, TOO.
I'M NOT HAPPY WITH MY HAIR.
I LOOK LIKE, YOU KNOW,
AN ALBINO PROSTITUTE.
Elyse: I COMPLETELY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND
ROBIN'S ASSERTION
THAT HER HAIRCUT
MADE HER LOOK LIKE A PROSTITUTE,
BUT THEN AGAIN,
I'M NOT REALLY FAMILIAR
WITH PROSTITUTE TRENDS.
(telephone rings)
(ring)
Nicole: I HAVEN'T TALKED
TO MY BOYFRIEND
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE,
AND I NEED HIM.
I NEED TO TALK TO HIM
TO GET THROUGH MY DAY.
Nicole's mother: Honey,
he should be home.
He called me and told me
he was going to be,
and then now he's not.
Nicole: OKAY, I CAN'T EVEN,
LIKE, THINK THAT.
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS THAT
I'M AVOIDING THINKING ABOUT.
Nicole's mother: Cory is
unreachable as usual.
Nicole: MY FEARS ARE BEING
DEPENDENT ON SOMEBODY ELSE
AND MAYBE NOT DOING WHAT
I WANNA DO.
I MISS HIM A LOT.
Nicole's mother: Stop trying.
Nicole: NIGHT.
♪♪♪
Jay: HEY, COME TO
THE LIVING ROOM.
I BROUGHT STUFF FOR YOU GUYS.
Shannon: HI.
Jay: COME, COME, COME, COME.
I WENT TO REVLON TODAY,
AS YOU CAN SEE.
ALL RIGHT, THERE ARE
FOUR HUGE BAGS OF MAKEUP HERE.
NOW YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
YOU DIDN'T LIKE YOUR HAIR.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
- Ebony: YES.
Jay: IF THEY WANTED TO SHAVE
A STRIP DOWN THE MIDDLE
OF YOUR HEAD...
- Ebony: THAT'S FINE.
- Jay: THAT'S COOL.
- Ebony: MM-HMM.
- Jay: ALL RIGHT?
AND THE SAME THING, NICOLE--
YOU WERE LIKE, "I CAN'T HAVE
THEM TAKE OUT MY WEAVE.
I SPENT $1,500."
YOU JUST TOLD THE WORLD
IF THERE WAS
A HUGE HAIR COMPANY OUT THERE,
"WE'RE NOT GONNA GIVE THAT GIRL
A $300,000 HAIR CAMPAIGN,
'CAUSE SHE DOESN'T WANNA
TAKE OUT HER $1,500 WEAVE."
ROBIN, YOU HAVE REAL ISSUES
WITH YOUR HAIR,
AND YOU SAID
YOU FEEL LIKE A CLOWN.
YOU GOTTA UNDERSTAND,
YOU'RE HERE TO COMPETE,
TO BECOME A TOP MODEL.
IF NOT,
YOU MIGHT AS WELL GO HOME
AND JUST BE MISS SOY MILK
OR WHATEVER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN,
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
Robin: SOYBEAN.
Jay: SOYBEAN. SOY LATTE.
WHATEVER.
THE POINT IS,
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
DO YOU WANNA BE A TOP MODEL,
OR YOU WANNA GO HOME?
SO TODAY YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
MEET UP WITH DEREK KHAN.
HE'S GONNA TAKE YOU
THROUGH SOME STYLING THINGS,
AND WHEN I MEET UP WITH YOU
AND DEREK,
WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A LITTLE COMPETITION.
I'M GONNA ASK YOU GUYS
TO TAKE YOURSELVES
FROM DAY TO NIGHT.
THERE IS A BIG EVENT TONIGHT
THAT CAN MOVE ONE OF YOU GIRLS
UP IN THE MODELING CAREER.
IT'S UP TO THE EIGHT OF YOU LEFT
TO COMPETE AMONGST EACH OTHER
TO GET TO BE THE ONE
WHO GETS TO GO WITH US.
OKAY, AND WHAT I WANT YOU GUYS
TO DO IS GO THROUGH THE BAGS.
REVLON HAS SUPPLIED YOU
THE MAKEUP,
AND YOU HAVE TO FIND YOUR
FOUNDATION COLOR AND POWDER.
Ebony: BASICALLY,
BEING A MAKEUP ARTIST,
I JUMPED AROUND
TO A DIFFERENT COMPANY,
TRYING TO GET, YOU KNOW,
DIFFERENT TYPES
OF PIECES OF KNOWLEDGE.
YOU HAVE A BRUSH?
- Robin: YEAH.
- Ebony: OKAY. GET YOUR BRUSH.
SO I KNOW IT COMES EASIER TO ME
THAN IT MIGHT COME TO THE GIRLS.
BRUSH IT ON A LITTLE BIT.
YOU GOT IT?
IT LOOKS GOOD ALREADY, OKAY?
Robin: THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
Derek: WELCOME,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, LADIES.
Tyra: DEREK KHAN
IS A DIVA STYLIST.
FOR THE GIRLS TO DEVELOP
THEIR OWN STYLE,
I WANT TO EXPOSE THEM
TO THE TOP LEVEL OF FASHION
IN NEW YORK CITY.
Adrianne: MADISON AVENUE
IS A PLACE
FOR VERY, VERY RICH FOLK.
Elyse: IT WAS FUN TO SEE
OBSCENELY EXPENSIVE
CLOTHES AND SHOES AND JEWELRY.
Shannon: THE JEWELRY
WAS ABSOLUTELY BREATHTAKING.
Adrianne: IT'S WORTH MORE THAN,
LIKE, EVERYTHING MY WHOLE
IMMEDIATE FAMILY HAS EVER OWNED.
Kesse: I THOUGHT DEREK
WAS REALLY FUNNY.
Derek: LIKE, OKAY,
"I HAVE LOVELY CLEAVAGE."
SHOW THAT DAMN THING.
"I HAVE A BEAUTIFUL BOOTY."
SHOW IT!
Kesse: HE'S KINDA LIKE
THE GIRLFRIEND THAT YOU WANNA
TALK TO AND LAUGH.
Derek: LET THAT DROP, HONEY.
YOU WILL BE MODELING
FOR THE REST OF YOUR DAYS.
OKAY, DON'T FORGET.
LET'S PAT THEM DOWN NOW,
BECAUSE I KNOW THE RING--
SOMEBODY GOT A RING
IN THEIR POCKET.
♪♪♪
Elyse: ADRIANNE AND I
KEPT JOKING ABOUT
PRETENDING THAT WE WERE RICH,
AND EVERYBODY WAS SHOCKED
WHEN ROBIN PROVED
THAT SHE REALLY IS RICH.
Derek: SHE'S ACTUALLY SHOPPING.
Elyse: BY PRETTY OSTENTATIOUSLY
THROWING DOWN
FOR THAT OSTENTATIOUS
PAIR OF BOOTS.
Derek: OH, THESE ARE DIVINE.
Robin: I PURCHASED
A PAIR OF BOOTS, BUT I MEAN,
IT WAS NOTHING.
YOUR FEET ARE WHAT HOLD YOU UP,
SO THEREFORE,
YOU MUST WEAR A GOOD SHOE.
I JUST LOVE GOING SHOPPING.
THAT'S, LIKE, MY WEAKNESS.
Derek: LET'S SEE YOU DIVAS.
THIS LOOKS GORGEOUS ON YOU.
THIS IS NOT HOW THE TOP WORKS,
BUT GUESS WHAT.
SHE MADE IT WORK.
THIS IS A LITTLE TOO...
SHOPPING SPREE.
A TOP LIKE THIS
MAKES IT A LITTLE HOOCHIE-FIED.
Jay: HEY, GIRLS.
Women: HI!
Jay: WOW,
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN BUSY.
DEREK'S BEEN BUSY,
MY GOSH.
THIS IS THE MAKEUP CHALLENGE,
ALL RIGHT?
SO YOU GUYS
ARE ALL LOOKING BEAUTIFUL.
YOU DID YOUR KIND OF DAY MAKEUP.
SO NOW WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO
IS TRANSFORM YOURSELF
INTO EVENING,
AND REVLON SENT MAKEUP.
SO EVERYTHING YOU NEED
IS IN THE BAG.
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
JUST ONE WINNER GETS TO GO
TO A REALLY BIG,
FABULOUS FUNCTION TONIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TEN MINUTES,
AND I'M GONNA PICK THE WINNER.
Elyse: I THINK THAT EVERYONE
WAS REALLY, REALLY NERVOUS,
AND WE WERE ALL KIND OF
STARTING TO CHOMP AT THE BIT.
Jay: HERE'S A STOPWATCH.
SO 3... 2... 1. LET'S GO.
♪♪♪
Jay: WE'RE JUST GOING
ON THE LAST MINUTE.
♪♪♪
Jay: 3... 2... 1.
ALL RIGHT, EVERYTHING'S
GOTTA GO DOWN RIGHT NOW.
DOES THIS LOOK LIKE
WHAT I DID YESTERDAY?
- Ebony: NO.
- Jay: OKAY.
Ebony: I DID THIS
HORRIBLE MAKEUP ON MYSELF.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE IT WAS ME.
I'M TRIPPING, I KNOW,
I'M NOT THINKING, YOU'RE RIGHT.
I'M A MAKEUP ARTIST, I KNOW.
Jay: ONE OF THE THINGS I SAID
IS NEVER MATCH YOUR OUTFIT
WITH YOUR EYE SHADOW.
Jay: THIS IS, LIKE,
LOOKING CLOSE,
BUT THAT'S A GOOD TRY.
ELYSE, IT'S LOOKING GOOD.
ALL RIGHT, NICOLE.
Nicole: YOU'RE GONNA LAUGH
AT MY EYELASHES.
- Jay: YEAH, YOU NEED PRACTICE.
- Nicole: YEAH.
Jay: GISELLE?
IT'S GREAT, BUT REMEMBER,
YESTERDAY WE TALKED ABOUT
MINIMIZING THE WIDTH
OF YOUR FACE.
REMEMBER HOW WE BRONZED
AND SHAPED YOUR FACE?
Giselle: AH!
THAT'S WHAT I DID.
Jay: ROBIN,
THIS IS PRETTY CLOSE.
GIVEN YOUR MOOD YESTERDAY,
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU ACTUALLY
TOOK ANYTHING IN.
SHANNON, REMEMBER WHEN
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
CUTTING THE LASHES
USING A PIECE ON THE END?
Shannon: I DID.
Jay: YEAH, BUT YOU GOT 'EM
BACK TO FRONT.
KESSE, THE ONLY THING
THAT I REALLY WOULD'VE DONE
IS TRY TO RIM YOUR EYES
AND TRY TO SMOKE IT OUT
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
SO... I HAVE TO PICK
JUST ONE WINNER WHO GETS TO GO
TO THE INDIAN CONSULATE TONIGHT
TO MEET SOME
VERY INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
I HONESTLY HAVE TO SAY,
ELYSE, I THINK YOU WON.
Elyse: THANK YOU.
Jay: YOU DID THE CLOSEST.
SHE GOT THE EXACT NUMBER
OF LASHES I TOLD HER TO PUT ON.
SHE PUT IT IN
THE EXACT SAME SPOT,
SO SHE DID EXACTLY WHAT I ASKED.
ELYSE, YOU GET TO CHOOSE
THREE GIRLS TO GO WITH YOU.
Elyse: OKAY, NICOLE,
THANK YOU FOR THE SCISSORS.
I CHOOSE YOU.
ADRIANNE, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE MASCARA.
I CHOOSE YOU.
THE LAST GIRL I CHOSE RANDOMLY.
UM, SO I GUESS
IT COULD HAVE BEEN ANYONE.
DOES ANYONE'S MOTHER'S
MAIDEN NAME START WITH A "G"?
BUT, UM, IT WAS ROBIN.
ROBIN, I CHOOSE YOU.
Nicole: I'M NOT
FEELING VERY GOOD.
- Jay: WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
- Elyse: SHE DOESN'T WANNA GO.
Nicole: I FIGURE IF I GO
AND I FEEL SICK WHILE I'M THERE,
SO I'M NOT GONNA GO AND NOT
FEEL GOOD THE WHOLE TIME.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
Jay: SO JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT FEELING WELL,
YOU DON'T WANNA GO?
Nicole: SHOULD THERE BE
A BETTER REASON?
Jay: WELL, I MEAN,
YOU DON'T LOOK DEATHLY ILL.
Nicole: NO, I'M DEFINITELY
NOT DEATHLY ILL.
I JUST DON'T FEEL VERY GOOD.
Jay: YOU REALIZE
WHAT YOU'RE TURNING DOWN.
YOU'RE TURNING DOWN
AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ADVANCE YOUR CAREER.
I MEAN, YOU STILL GOTTA THINK
ABOUT IT.
I MEAN, THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF GIRLS WHO STILL
WANNA BE IN YOUR SPOT,
WHETHER THEY HAD
THE FLU, FEVER, WHATEVER.
Kesse: IF IT HAD BEEN ME,
I WOULD HAVE GONE,
NO DOUBT, NO SECOND THOUGHTS.
Elyse: IT'S NOT WORTH
ALIENATING THE JUDGES,
AND I DON'T THINK SHE CAME UP
WITH A GOOD ENOUGH EXCUSE.
Jay: THAT'S FINE
IF THAT'S YOUR DECISION,
BUT YOU REALIZE
YOU COULD BE PUTTING
SOMEONE ELSE AHEAD OF YOU.
YOU COULD JUST BE CUT THIS WEEK.
Nicole: WELL, IF I'M CUT
THIS WEEK BECAUSE OF THIS,
THEN THAT'S SILLY.
Jay: SO THEN IT'S SILLY
AND YOU GO BACK HOME
AND YOU DO WHAT,
WORK AT BURGER KING?
Nicole: YOU KNOW WHAT? OKAY.
NO, I'M NOT GOING.
Adrianne: YOU DON'T THINK
I HAVE FAKE EYELASHES ON, RIGHT?
Nicole: CAN YOU NOT TALK
TO ME ABOUT YOUR EYELASHES?
I REALLY DON'T CARE.
Adrianne: WHOA, DUDE,
I'M SORRY.
NICOLE NOT WANTING TO GO--
I THINK THAT WAS KINDA DUMB.
AND IN A WAY, I THINK SHE KINDA
WANTED TO GO HOME
AND JUST CALL HER BOYFRIEND.
Nicole: OH, WHATEVER.
♪♪♪
Derek: LADIES AND GENTLEMAN,
WELCOME TO
THE INDIAN COMMISSION.
Robin: IT WAS JUST
AN EXPERIENCE.
Derek: WE HAVE ALL
MY DEAR FRIENDS IN FASHION HERE.
YOU HAVE SOME OF
THE BEST PROFESSIONALS
IN OUR BUSINESS--
MAXIMILLIAN TUCCI,
JANICE COMBS,
CONSTANCE WHITE,
A TOP FASHION JOURNALIST.
Constance: HI, LADIES.
Robin: WELL, I COULD TELL,
LIKE, THEY WERE VERY WEALTHY,
AND THEY KNEW A LOT
ABOUT FASHION.
Derek: THIS IS OUR DESIGNER
FOR THE EVENING, ANAND JON.
ANAND'S ABSOLUTELY BRILLIANT.
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS GET
SOME OF HIS GARMENTS ON YOU,
AND WE'RE GOING TO CRITIQUE IT.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: YOU KNOW,
IF YOU'RE A MODEL,
YOU GOTTA BE COMFORTABLE
WITH YOUR BODY,
AND HERE I AM,
JUST BOOBS THE ENTIRE TIME,
AND I DIDN'T CARE,
SO I HOPE THAT, LIKE,
IT COUNTS FOR SOMETHING.
Constance: UM, ADRIANNE--
I REALLY LIKED HER LOOK.
I THOUGHT SHE HAD
A SENSUOUSNESS AND SEXUALITY.
Derek: SHE'S JUST RAIL-THIN.
I LOVE IT.
Constance: ELYSE, I THOUGHT,
HAD A REALLY GOOD LOOK
FOR THE RUNWAY.
Derek: WE HAVE
OUR GLAMOURPUSS HERE.
Constance: ROBIN IS AN
INTERESTING CASE.
THE INDUSTRY
FOR LARGE SIZES IS BOOMING.
(horn honks)
Nicole: IF NONE OF THIS
HAPPENS FOR ME,
I THINK I'M GONNA
START CONSIDERING,
YOU KNOW, GETTING MARRIED
AND HAVING BABIES.
- BABY?
- Cory: Hi, honey.
Nicole: I DON'T WANNA FIGHT,
I DON'T WANNA ARGUE WITH YOU,
BUT I JUST--I JUST--I'M SORRY.
I'M NOT HAPPY WITH YOU
RIGHT NOW, BABE.
ARE YOU JUST PARTYING,
OR WHAT'S THE DEAL?
Cory: You're the one that
needs to get ahold of me
when you have a second
and let me know
when I can call you.
Nicole: BABY, I HAVE
CALLED YOU EVERY SINGLE DAY,
FOUR TIMES A DAY
FOR THE LAST SIX DAYS.
DID YOU TRY TO CALL ME
YESTERDAY?
- Cory: No.
- Nicole: DAY BEFORE?
Cory: No.
Nicole: DAY BEFORE?
Cory: No. I haven't tried
to call you at all.
Nicole: CORY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE NOT BEING
A SUPPORTIVE BOYFRIEND, CORY.
YOU'RE REALLY NOT RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE NOT.
Man: NOW YOU--
YOU'RE ALWAYS SMILING,
BUT WHAT THAT'S TRANSLATING
TO IS DEFINITELY, LIKE,
A SPOKESPERSON KIND OF A MODEL.
YOU--DEFINITE RUNWAY.
Elyse: THERE WERE A LOT
OF IMPORTANT PEOPLE THERE.
Adrianne: I'VE BEEN REJECTED
FOR EIGHT YEARS IN THE BUSINESS,
AND I'M JUST BEING TOLD
AT THE CONSULATE
THAT I WAS
DEFINITE PRINT MATERIAL.
Robin: YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT
EVERYBODY NEEDS THAT EXPOSURE,
THAT EXPERIENCE.
SO I THINK NICOLE DID MISS OUT.
Jay: WITH NICOLE NOT BEING HERE,
DO ANY OF THESE WOMEN
KNOW WHAT SHE LOOKS LIKE?
Nicole: SO, BABE,
SO ARE YOU HAVING A GOOD TIME?
ARE WE GROWING APART?
TELL ME WHAT'S ON YOUR MIND.
Cory: The only reason
I'm being a... is because
I'm feeling really insecure
about my girlfriend
with really hot guys
in New York.
Nicole: OKAY.
Cory: If I act like a...
you'll want me more.
Nicole: NO, IF YOU ACT LIKE
A... I'M GONNA HANG UP ON YOU
AND SAY... OFF.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GONNA DO, CORY.
YOUR REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY'S
...ASS.
YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BE NICE TO ME.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA LISTEN TO ME.
Nicole: I HAVE TO CRY TO YOU.
I HAVE THINGS I WANNA SAY
TO YOU.
I'M SAD. I'M LONELY.
I MISS YOU. I NEED SUPPORT.
SO WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO DO?
YOU WANT ME TO DROP OUT
RIGHT NOW?
Cory: I don't know.
♪♪♪
Jon: HEY, SURPRISE.
GOOD MORNING, WANNABE MODELS.
WAKE UP.
YOU GOT 15 MINUTES
TO MEET ME UPSTAIRS.
WE'RE WORKING OUT
IN THIS BUILDING TODAY.
Elyse: JON THE TRAINER
IS SUPPOSED TO WHIP US ALL
INTO SHAPE AND GET US ALL
TO TONE UP LIKE THE JUDGES
TOLD EVERYBODY TO DO.
Jon: DRIVE IT UP. GOOD.
Adrianne: THIS TRAINER
SO HAS ME PSYCHED,
'CAUSE I LOVE TO WORK OUT.
(grunts)
Jon: ADRIANNE IS
AN EXTREME INDIVIDUAL.
SHE IS IN PHENOMENAL CONDITION.
ONE MORE. REAL SLOW, REAL SLOW.
Adrianne: ROB WAS VERY,
VERY, VERY LATE,
BECAUSE SHE WAS
PRIMPING HERSELF IN THE MIRROR.
Jon: DID YOU JUST COME IN?
COME HERE FOR A SECOND.
HAVE A SEAT AGAINST THIS WALL
FOR A SECOND.
GET INTO THIS POSITION
LIKE THIS AND JUST STAY HERE.
THERE'S NO REASON TO BE LATE.
DOWN LOWER. RIGHT THERE.
STAY THERE.
Adrianne: (grunts)
Jon: LOOK AT THAT.
SHE'S NUTS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GOTTA DO.
YOU GOTTA GET SO PSYCHO
THAT YOU DO THAT.
Adrianne: I THINK I'VE SHOWN
THAT I HAVE A LOT OF DRIVE,
AND I HOPE MISS TYRA
AND THE REST SEE THAT.
Jon: YOUR LEGS ARE WARM NOW?
YOU FEEL THAT?
OKAY, COME OVER HERE.
HAVE A SEAT RIGHT HERE.
DO THAT NOW, OKAY?
PUSH AS HARD AS YOU CAN
TILL YOU CAN'T DO ANY MORE.
Robin: TO BE HONEST,
I THINK JON IS GOOD,
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
JUST SOME OF THE STUFF
DIDN'T REALLY FLY RIGHT WITH ME.
Jon: ROBIN WAS SLACKING,
AND SHE WAS LACKING
IN HER ABILITY TO DO
THE EXERCISES EFFECTIVELY.
SHE WAS CHEATING ON
SOME OF THEM.
Giselle: IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
EVERYTHING THAT SHE DOES
SHE ALWAYS HAS
SOME KIND OF ATTITUDE.
Jon: DID YOU JUST FINISH
YOUR SET?
DID YOU PUSH THAT SET?
WOULD YOU BE HAPPY
WITH THE SET THAT YOU JUST DID
IF THAT WAS THE ONLY SET
YOU COULD DO?
IF THAT WAS
THE ONLY SET YOU COULD DO,
YOU WOULD BE HAPPY WITH IT?
YOU PUSHED YOURSELF HARD ENOUGH?
COME OVER HERE.
I'M GETTING THE FEELING
YOU'RE NOT WORKING HARD ENOUGH
FOR SOME REASON.
I DON'T KNOW WHY,
I'M JUST GETTING THE FEELING
THAT YOU'RE NOT
WORKING HARD ENOUGH.
Kesse: I THINK SHE JUST FELT
LIKE EVERYBODY WAS JUST
PICKING ON HER.
Adrianne: SHE GETS WHAT
SHE WANTS A LOT,
AND WHEN SHE DOESN'T GET
WHAT SHE WANTS,
I THINK SHE GETS UPSET.
IF I WAS A DESIGNER
OR A PHOTOGRAPHER,
HELL IF I'D WANNA WORK WITH HER.
♪♪♪
Tyra: ALL WEEK, THE GIRLS
HAVE BEEN LEARNING ABOUT
MAKEUP--
ALL FACETS OF MAKEUP.
SO I WANTED TO TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL
WITH A BEAUTY SHOOT TO SEE
WHO HAS WHAT IT TAKES
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
AS YOU GUYS KNOW,
TODAY WE'RE DOING BEAUTY SHOTS.
WITH BEAUTY, IT'S HERE.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE FORGIVENESS.
NOT EVERY MODEL CAN DO
BEAUTY SHOTS.
SO THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT DAY
TO SEE WHO'S GONNA GO
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
AND WE'RE NOT
JUST DOING TYPICAL BEAUTY SHOTS.
WE'RE DOING EXTREME
BEAUTY SHOTS.
Jay: EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF YOU
ARE GONNA HAVE A STRONG CONCEPT.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
KIND OF SOFT AND PRETTY.
SOME OF IT'S GONNA BE VERY EDGY.
SO IT'S GONNA BE ALL ABOUT
GETTING YOUR LOOK ON
AND THEN AS SOON AS YOU SEE IT,
TRY TO BE THAT PERSON,
BE THAT CHARACTER.
Tyra: SO WE HAVE
AN AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHER HERE--
MR. TROY WARD.
Troy: THIS IS REALLY
JUST GONNA BE
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING AND FEELING.
IT'S GONNA BE RIGHT IN ON YOU,
SO IT REALLY COMES
FROM THE EYES.
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER MODEL
THAT YOU'RE GONNA WORK WITH
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
Nicole: I'M LIKE,
KIND OF, LIKE, WONDERING,
MAYBE IT'S SOMEONE FAMOUS.
Troy: WE'VE BROUGHT MODELS IN
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
TO BE WITH US HERE.
Nicole: AND THEY WALK IN
WITH THESE HUGE SNAKES.
OH, MY GOD. I ALMOST CRIED.
Adrianne: I MISS MY SNAKE
SO MUCH.
I HAVE A SNAKE NAMED BRIGITTA,
AND IT'S A BALL PYTHON.
Troy: REALLY?
SO YOU'LL BE RIGHT AT HOME.
Adrianne: THE OTHER GIRLS--
THEY WERE ALL LIKE,
"OOH-WEE.
THEY BROUGHT IN A SNAKE.
I AIN'T TAKING PICTURES
WITH A SNAKE."
Robin: I'VE NEVER TOUCHED
A SNAKE BEFORE.
I DON'T PLAY WITH REPTILES,
AND, YOU KNOW, AMPHIBIANS
AND ALL THAT.
Troy: DO YOU FEEL GORGEOUS?
Robin: YEAH.
Troy: YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE IT,
'CAUSE IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT,
I WON'T BELIEVE IT.
Robin: I THOUGHT
THAT WAS THAT SNAKE.
(laughter)
Troy: THERE'S A LOT
OF EMOTION IN YOUR EYES NOW.
THAT'S GOOD, BABY.
I BELIEVE IT.
Tyra: WITH THE SNAKES INVOLVED,
I WAS LOOKING
FOR SOMEONE THAT COULD STILL
HAVE THE CONCENTRATION TO SELL
THAT PICTURE GORGEOUSLY
RIGHT HERE WITHOUT GOING,
"EHH."
YOU ARE SO MUCH BIGGER
THAN THE SNAKE.
LET'S TRY THAT.
Robin: I WEAR
SNAKESKIN BOOTS, BUT,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T HAVE TO SEE IT
AND FEEL IT AND... MM.
IT JUST WASN'T...
ECCH! OOH, GET HIM, GET HIM,
GET HIM, GET HIM, GET HIM.
I HAD TO CALL ON JESUS,
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TIMES.
OOH, JESUS, JESUS, JESUS.
Woman: TAKE A BREATH.
TAKE A BREATH.
Robin: JESUS.
OOH, IT'S TICKLING
UP UNDER MY ARM.
Troy: ROBIN WAS A LITTLE BIT
FROZEN BY EVERYTHING
THAT WAS GOING ON AROUND HER,
BUT SHE'S BEAUTIFUL.
I MEAN, SHE'S DEFINITELY
VERY BEAUTIFUL.
Robin: THE END PRODUCT
IS GLAMOROUS,
BUT WHAT IT TAKES TO GET TO THAT
IS NOT SO GLAMOROUS.
Troy: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE
GILDING A FRAME.
Tyra: EVERY GIRL WAS GIVEN
A DIFFERENT CHARACTER,
AND I WAS WATCHING THEM TO SEE
HOW WELL YOU CAN EXPRESS
THAT CHARACTER
THROUGH THE CAMERA LENS.
Troy: RIGHT THERE.
OKAY, GOOD.
ALMOST LIKE A BIRD.
YOU'VE JUST POPPED OUT
OF AN EGG.
THAT'S IT. NICE. BEAUTIFUL.
THAT'S GREAT, ELYSE.
I LOVE IT. RIGHT THERE.
ELYSE IS VERY AWARE OF HER BODY,
AND SHE THINKS
ABOUT THE SHOT.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH,
JUST RELAX.
GONNA BE FINE.
BEAUTIFUL. THAT'S IT.
Tyra: A LITTLE BIT MORE
"I'M SO CUTE."
SMILE WITH YOUR EYES
A LITTLE BIT.
Troy: GOOD. RIGHT THERE.
KESSE'S GOOD.
SHE'S GOT THE SORT OF LIKE
DOE-LIKE LOOK ABOUT HER.
Tyra: WE GOT IT.
♪♪♪
Troy: BEAUTIFUL.
THE THING ABOUT EBONY
IS HER SKIN.
I MEAN, YOU CAN FAKE IT
A LITTLE BIT WITH RETOUCHING.
BUT RETOUCHING'S EXPENSIVE.
Adrianne: THAT IS SO COOL.
Tyra: VERY '80s.
Troy: SHANNON'S GOT
A REALLY BEAUTIFUL LOOK.
I THINK SHE ACTUALLY LOOKS
BETTER ON CAMERA
THAN SHE DID
WHEN I JUST LOOKED AT HER.
Tyra: YOURS LOOKS GREAT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: YEAH, GISELLE,
DON'T PUSH YOUR CHIN SO FORWARD
THAT YOU LOSE YOUR NECK.
Troy: BEAUTIFUL.
GISELLE WAS VERY BRAVE.
SHE'S VERY EXOTIC. BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL.
SHE'S VERY GOOD.
- HOLD ON.
- Giselle: IT'S CHOKING ME.
Troy: THAT'S RIGHT.
Giselle: THE SNAKE'S PRETTY.
Tyra: YOU DON'T THINK
YOU LOOK PRETTY?
Nicole: MY WORST FEAR
IS SNAKES, RIGHT?
NEVER, EVER THINKING THAT THEY
WOULD EVER DO ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
I MEAN, THAT'S JUST,
YOU KNOW, WEIRD.
OH, BOY.
- Troy: HE DOESN'T EXIST.
- Nicole: OKAY.
OH, WHERE'S THE HEAD
OF THE SNAKE?
THE ONLY REASON THAT I WAS OKAY
WITH HAVING A SNAKE
AROUND MY NECK IS 'CAUSE
I DON'T WANT, YOU KNOW,
ANY OF MY DECISIONS
WHILE I'M HERE
TO AFFECT THE OUTCOME OF WHETHER
OR NOT I MAKE IT TO THE END.
Troy: GOOD. THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL.
GIVE ME JUST A LITTLE HINT
OF A SMILE.
REALLY GIVE ME THE EYES THERE.
Tyra: YOUR EYES
ARE A LITTLE DEAD.
SMILE WITH YOUR EYES
AND CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
Troy: NICOLE WAS
A LITTLE BIT LIMITED
IN THE RANGE
THAT SHE WOULD GIVE ME.
THINK OF SOMETHING REALLY GOOD,
LIKE GETTING THIS SNAKE
OFF YOUR SHOULDERS.
OKAY.
Adrianne: I'M GONNA LOOK HOT.
Tyra: I FEEL LIKE
I'M GIVING HER A NOSE JOB.
Adrianne: THEY CALL IT
"THE MASK OF ZORRO."
IT WAS, LIKE, PURPLE,
AND IT WAS COOL.
I LOOKED LIKE THE HAMBURGLAR.
Troy: NICE HAVING TYRA HERE
HELPING YOU.
IT'S LIKE HAVING MICHAEL JORDAN
TEACH YOU HOW TO SHOOT
FREE THROWS.
Tyra: OKAY. SNAKE!
Adrianne: I HAVE A SNAKE,
AND I WAS THE ONLY ONE
THAT WASN'T A PUSS ABOUT IT,
BECAUSE I LOVE SNAKES.
AW.
Woman: LIKE... (hissing)
Troy: YEAH, THAT'S IT.
THINK REALLY STRONG, ADRIANNE.
YOU'RE LIKE SUPERWOMAN.
I THINK IF WAS GONNA BOOK
A GIRL TODAY BASED ON
WHERE THEY ARE RIGHT NOW,
I WOULD PROBABLY PICK ADRIANNE.
SHE'S VERY BEAUTIFUL.
SHE HAS A GOOD TIME.
I THINK IT WOULD BE FUN
TO WORK WITH HER.
OKAY, I THINK WE GOT IT.
YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I MEAN, THAT'S LIKE A COVER.
Tyra: THAT'S A WRAP.
♪♪♪
Kesse: "TOMORROW SEVEN OF YOU
"WILL CONTINUE ON TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Giselle: OH, NO.
THEY WERE STARING AT
YOUR PICTURES FOREVER, NICOLE.
- Nicole: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
- Giselle: I DON'T KNOW.
YOU'RE BEING ELIMINATED, NICOLE,
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS.
Nicole: YEAH, RIGHT.
I AIN'T GOING NOWHERE.
I STILL HAVE TWO MORE WEEKS'
WORTH OF CLOTHES, BABY.
Giselle: YOU BETTER WORK IT OUT.
Adrianne: I THINK
I DID A GOOD JOB THIS WEEK.
I KNOW I'M NOT GONNA GET
ELIMINATED,
BECAUSE I JUST TRIED
TOO DAMN HARD,
AND I THINK THAT GOD'S
GONNA BLESS ME.
- Ebony: ADRIANNE IS SICK, GUYS.
- Shannon: WHAT?
Ebony: SHE'S LIKE,
"YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED?"
SHE'S BEEN SO QUIET,
LIKE, FOR THREE HOURS.
LISTEN. NOTHING.
Adrianne: I JUST DON'T WANNA
THROW UP IN A BAG.
Ebony: OH. WATCH IT.
SHE DOESN'T FEEL GOOD.
POOR BABY.
Giselle: I GO OVER
AND CHECK ON HER,
AND SHE'S IN THE BATHROOM, LIKE,
SHIVERING AND CRYING.
IT JUST REALLY HURTS ME
TO SEE HER SICK LIKE THAT,
ESPECIALLY WHEN
TONIGHT'S ELIMINATION.
Adrianne: I DON'T WANNA
STAND UP STRAIGHT, PLEASE.
Giselle: PUT THE BLANKET ON HER.
SHE'S BEING SHIPPED OFF
TO THE HOSPITAL RIGHT NOW,
AND IT'S REALLY SAD.
Adrianne: (groans)
I'M FEELING SO BAD,
AND I DON'T WANNA WALK.
(sobbing)
Kesse: ADRIANNE'S SO SICK.
I FEEL SO BAD,
I'VE NEVER SEEN HER LIKE THAT.
Adrianne: I HATE HOSPITALS.
I DON'T WANNA GO.
(moaning)
♪♪♪
Robin: ELIMINATION DAY,
AND EVERYBODY'S JUST
GETTING READY.
ADRIANNE GOT SICK TODAY.
Kesse: I TOLD HER THAT
I LOVED HER BEFORE SHE LEFT.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S MY GIRL,
SO, UM, I REALLY HOPE
SHE FEELS BETTER.
Tyra: I WOULD NEVER CUT
ADRIANNE FOR BEING SICK,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, THE JUDGES
CAME TO THE DECISION THAT
IF SHE WAS NOT PRESENT
DURING THE JUDGING,
SHE WOULD BE ELIMINATED
BECAUSE IT WOULDN'T BE FAIR
TO THE OTHER GIRLS
THAT WOULD BE PRESENT.
Shannon: HEY, ADRIANNE'S
GONNA MISS THIS ONE.
THAT'S GOTTA SUCK,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
- 'CAUSE SHE'S SICK.
- Kesse: YEAH.
Adrianne: THE DOCTOR TOLD ME
IT WAS A SEVERE CASE
OF FOOD POISONING.
I FAKED BEING BETTER
TO GET OUT OF THE HOSPITAL.
I'M NOT GONNA MISS ELIMINATION.
THERE'S NO WAY.
RIGHT NOW I FEEL
SO INCREDIBLY WEAK.
I CAN'T OPEN MY EYES.
I FEEL LIKE I CAN'T LIFT
2 POUNDS.
I FEEL LIKE HELL.
Elyse: I FULLY EXPECTED
ADRIANNE TO BE AT THE JUDGING
NO MATTER HOW SICK SHE WAS.
I KNEW THAT SHE WOULD INSIST
ON BEING THERE.
SHE'S A TOUGH BROAD,
AS SHE WOULD SAY
IN HER OWN WORDS.
Tyra: WELCOME, LADIES.
IT'S BEEN ANOTHER EVENTFUL WEEK
IN YOUR JOURNEY IN BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I KNOW THIS WEEK
HAS BEEN HARD-CORE.
A LOT OF YOU GUYS HAVE SAID,
"OH, YEAH, THIS IS NICE.
THIS IS FUN,"
BUT THIS WEEK GOT SERIOUS.
SO NOW YOU SEE
THIS BUSINESS IS NO GAME.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR THIRD CUT
TOWARDS DETERMINING WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A CONTRACT WITH REVLON,
A FASHION SPREAD
WITH "MARIE CLAIRE"
AND A CONTRACT WITH ONE
OF THE WORLD'S TOP AGENCIES--
WILHELMINA.
SO WE HAVE FIVE JUDGES.
FIRST, WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELS,
BEAU QUILLIAN,
THE FASHION EDITOR
AT "MARIE CLAIRE" MAGAZINE,
KIMORA LEE SIMMONS,
THE OWNER AND CREATIVE DIRECTOR
OF BABY PHAT FASHIONS,
AND THIS WEEK'S SPECIAL JUDGE--
MR. JAY MANUEL.
JAY HAS DEVISED A TEST.
Jay: TAKE A LOOK
AT THE MONITOR.
- Tyra: C'EST MOI.
- Janice: WHOA!
- Kimora: THIS IS TYRA!
- Janice: OW!
Jay: TYRA AND I DID
THIS LOOK.
WE WERE HAVING FUN ON A SHOOT,
AND WE WANTED TO DO
EXTREME BEAUTY, SO WE DID IT.
Tyra: YOU'RE NOT
ALWAYS GONNA HAVE
A GREAT MAKEUP ARTIST LIKE JAY,
SO YOU NEED TO KNOW HOW TO DO
ALL DIFFERENT STYLES OF MAKEUP.
Jay: SO THE TEST IS
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE 20 MINUTES.
YOU'RE EACH GONNA RECEIVE
A COPY OF THE PHOTOGRAPH.
WE'RE GONNA JUDGE TO SEE
WHO CAN GET THE CLOSEST
TO THIS LOOK.
Tyra: GO.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: MY TUMMY
JUST REALLY HURTS STILL,
AND I'M REALLY WEAK.
AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF MYSELF,
AND I HOPE
I DON'T GET ELIMINATED.
Janice: THERE YOU GO.
Jay: WHOA!
Beau: ADRIANNE, ARE YOU OKAY?
Adrianne: I THINK
I HAD FOOD POISONING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID, SO...
Janice: THE FACT OF
THE MATTER THAT YOU SHOWED UP
IS WHAT IT TAKES TO BE A MODEL
AND A SUPERMODEL.
WELL DONE. I APPLAUD THAT.
Jay: OH, YEAH,
I CAN'T BELIEVE--
THE FACE LOOKS AMAZING.
Tyra: THE FACE IS GOOD.
NOW WE'RE GONNA CHECK OUT
YOUR BEAUTY CLOSE-UP SHOOT
THAT YOU DID
WITH YOUR EXTREME MAKEUP.
- Adrianne: WHOA.
- Janice: MY!
Tyra: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT YOUR PICTURE?
Adrianne: I THINK
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
Janice: WELL,
YOU LOOK AMAZING.
Jay: YOU DIDN'T EVEN
LOOK SCARED OF IT.
I JUST LOVE YOUR CONFIDENCE.
Beau: YOU LOOK GORGEOUS,
VERY ENGAGED.
Adrianne: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
GUYS.
Tyra: WORK IT OUT!
Jay: ON THE MAKEOVER DAY,
WE STARTED PUTTING IN
EXTENSIONS.
Kimora: I LOVE THE HAIR.
Tyra: SO WHEN YOU'RE
IN THE CLUB,
"ALL THE GIRLS
WITH THE HAIR WEAVES,
RAISE THEIR HANDS!"
KESSE'S GONNA BE LIKE, "HEY!"
All: (laughing)
Tyra: GO TO YOUR PHOTO.
Janice: "THERE'S A FRICKIN'
SNAKE ON MY SHOULDER,
AND THIS IS WHAT'S
REGISTERED ON MY FACE."
Tyra: HELLO, NICOLE.
Beau: UM, IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
REALLY GAVE IT A GOOD TRY TO ME.
Nicole: THANK YOU.
Kimora: IT'S A BIT
TOO NATURAL AND TOO LIGHT.
IT SEEMED LIKE YOU WERE
SCARED OF IT.
Nicole: I KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN.
I SAW--I LOOKED AT A COUPLE
OF THE OTHER GIRLS,
I'M LIKE,
I COULD'VE GONE WAY MORE CRAZY.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, SO NOW
WE HAVE YOUR PHOTO SHOOT SHOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Nicole: IT'S GORGEOUS,
I LOVE IT.
Jay: THE LOOK IN YOUR EYES--
IT'S JUST--I DON'T KNOW.
- Tyra: A LITTLE BLANK?
- Nicole: REALLY?
Tyra: IT WAS A LITTLE
DIFFICULT CHOOSING YOUR PICTURES
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM DIDN'T
HAVE LIFE IN THE EYES.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
REALLY HAVE TO WORK ON
AND REALLY TRY TO PULL
OUT OF YOURSELF,
BECAUSE YOUR EYES
TEND TO GO VERY DEAD.
♪♪♪
- Tyra: ELYSE.
- Elyse: HI.
Tyra: I THINK YOU WENT
A LITTLE TOO CONSERVATIVE.
Jay: AND I'M SO SURPRISED
'CAUSE YOU WON
THE MAKEUP CHALLENGE.
Elyse: I'M SURE YOU GUYS
NOTICED I DID PUT ON HIGHLIGHTER
ON MY "CLEAVAGE."
Tyra: OH, YOU DID?
OH, I SEE IT.
IT'S SO VOLUPTUOUS. (laughs)
THERE IT IS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Elyse: SEXIER THAN WHEN
I WAS IN THE BIKINI LIKE...
Tyra: BECAUSE IT'S YOUR TYPE
OF SEXUALITY.
I THINK IT'S VERY SEXY.
Beau: GORGEOUS,
GORGEOUS PICTURE.
♪♪♪
Janice: OH, MY GOD.
THERE SHE IS!
Tyra: WHOO! SHANNON!
Janice: LOOK WHAT
THE CAT DRAGGED IN!
Beau: YOU'RE FROM OHIO.
I'M SURE THIS IS NOT REALLY
LIKE ANYTHING YOU'VE HAD
TO DO ON YOURSELF BEFORE,
SO IT LOOKS LIKE YOU GAVE IT
A PRETTY GOOD SHOT TO ME.
Janice: WHOA.
Jay: I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU NAILED THAT LOOK.
EVERYTHING WAS GOING ON.
YOU'RE TRYING NOT TO BREAK
THE LEAF,
YOU HAD THAT HUGE SNAKE
COME OVER YOUR SHOULDER,
SO I LOVE THAT.
Janice: THE ATTITUDE IS GREAT.
I'LL GIVE YOU A 10 ON THIS ONE.
♪♪♪
- Tyra: HEY!
- Giselle: HELLO.
Tyra: THE MAKEUP--
I DON'T LIKE IT, GISELLE.
(laughs)
Beau: "A" FOR EFFORT.
I THINK THAT YOU LOOK
SO REMARKABLE IN THIS PICTURE.
I DIDN'T EVEN RECOGNIZE YOU
WHEN I FIRST SAW IT.
Giselle: I FEEL LIKE
MY FACE LOOKS TOO PLAIN.
Tyra: I WOULD PUT THAT UP
IN MY LIVING ROOM AS ARTWORK.
I THINK IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
Jay: YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL
ON THE OUTSIDE,
AND YOU JUST NEED TO HAVE
THAT THOUGHT IN YOUR MIND.
♪♪♪
- Janice: OW!
- Jay: I'M SURPRISED.
Kimora: YOUR EYEBROWS
LOOK GREAT.
YOUR EYES LOOK GREAT.
- IT'S PERFECT.
- Robin: THANK YOU.
Tyra: HERE'S
YOUR PHOTO SHOOT SHOT.
Robin: THAT SNAKE...
- Jay: (laughing)
- Robin: THERE'S THE SNAKE.
Kimora: I THINK
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
Jay: I LOVE YOU, ROBIN,
BUT YOU JUST GIVE
SO MUCH ATTITUDE.
MAKEOVER DAY.
- OH, MY GOD, KIMORA.
- Kimora: ROBIN!
Tyra: SHE WAS JUST CRYIN'
AND ACTIN' A FOOL
AND BITCHIN' AND MOANIN'
AND BEIN' A DIVA,
BUT A DIVA IN THE WRONG,
NEGATIVE KIND OF WAY.
Robin: OKAY. I JUST--
Tyra: I'VE BEEN
THROUGH HAIR HELL.
Robin: RIGHT, EXACTLY.
Tyra: FRIED, DYED,
FALLIN' OUT, DREADLOCKS, AFRO,
PULLED BACK INTO A TIGHT BUN,
AND THEN FRIZZED OUT ALL IN
FIVE FASHION SHOWS IN ONE DAY.
JUST, THE POINT IS, ROBIN,
WHEN YOU GET TO THE REAL WORLD,
- THEY'LL JUST SAY, "BYE."
- Robin: RIGHT.
- Tyra: HEY, EBONY.
- Ebony: HELLO.
Tyra: IT LOOKS
A LITTLE CONSERVATIVE.
JAY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Jay: I'M ACTUALLY SURPRISED
AFTER YOU'VE BEEN BRAGGING
ABOUT BEING A MAKEUP ARTIST,
AND THEN EVERY TEST I GAVE YOU,
YOU FAILED.
Ebony: HONEY, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT WAS.
Jay: I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT WAS, EITHER.
Janice: I SEE NOTHING
VAGUELY SIMILAR
TO THIS MAKEUP WHATSOEVER.
Tyra: SO HERE'S YOUR SHOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Ebony: WELL, I LIKE MY SKIN.
Tyra: AND WITH
YOUR SKIN TEXTURE,
BEING AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMAN,
IT SHOULD BE LIKE BUTTAH.
AT THE RETOUCHING SESSION,
YOUR PHOTO WAS THE HARDEST
THAT WE HAD TO DO.
♪♪♪
Tyra: GUYS, NOW IT'S TIME
TO DELIBERATE,
AND TO ME,
THIS WEEK IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
ADRIANNE.
Beau: THE FACT THAT SHE
WAS SO ILL...
Janice: SHE WORKED IT.
SHE HAS A GREAT ATTITUDE.
I REALLY LOVE THE PHOTOGRAPH.
- Tyra: KESSE.
- Kimora: OUT.
- Beau: IN.
- Janice: SHE LOOKS AFRAID
TO ME THERE. SORRY.
Tyra: SHANNON.
- Kimora: IN.
- Beau: IN.
I THINK SHE'S ACTUALLY MADE
A LOT OF IMPROVEMENT.
- Tyra: ELYSE.
- Kimora: IN.
Janice: IN.
STUNNING MAKEUP.
STUNNING GIRL.
I THINK SHE'S PERFECT.
Tyra: NICOLE.
Kimora: I THINK SHE'S
A GREAT, CUTE GIRL IN PERSON.
I DON'T THINK
SHE'S THE MOST PHOTOGENIC.
Tyra: I FEEL LIKE SHE DOESN'T
WANNA BE HERE.
Jay: THEN THAT JUST BOTHERS ME.
Tyra: GISELLE.
Kimora: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT WHOLE PUTTING YOURSELF
THAT DOWN THING,
IT COMPLETELY TURNS ME OFF.
Beau: I UNDERSTAND
EVERYBODY'S RESERVATIONS
ABOUT HER SELF-IMAGE PROBLEMS,
BUT THE THING FOR ME IS IT
DOESN'T SHOW IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
Tyra: ROBIN.
Kimora: I THINK
ROBIN IS A GORGEOUS GIRL.
I WAS SO DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR
THAT SHE HAD A BAD ATTITUDE.
Tyra: THAT DIVA THING
TURNED ME OFF.
EBONY.
Jay: I LOVE
THE COLOR OF HER SKIN.
I REALLY DO, BUT UP CLOSE,
SHE JUST LOOKED SO OLD.
Kimora: EBONY JUST
IS MUCH TOO HARSH FOR ME.
I JUST DON'T GET IT.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
WE'VE REACHED OUR DECISION.
THERE ARE EIGHT OF YOU
IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SEVEN PICTURES
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE SEVEN PICTURES
REPRESENT THE SEVEN OF YOU
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SHANNON.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
KESSE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
ELYSE. CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
GISELLE.
GISELLE, IF YOU DON'T THINK
YOU'RE FIERCE, THEN I WON'T.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ADRIANNE.
ADRIANNE, I HAVE TO COMMEND YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
THERE IS A BALANCE, THOUGH,
AND IN YOUR QUEST
FOR WINNING THIS CONTEST,
JUST MAKE SURE YOU KNOW HOW FAR
TO PUSH YOURSELF.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Tyra: ROBIN.
ROBIN, THE WHOLE TANTRUM THING--
WE'RE ONLY GONNA ALLOW
ONE OF THOSE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL EBONY AND NICOLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Tyra: I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND WHOEVER RECEIVES THIS PHOTO
WILL CONTINUE
ON THE JOURNEY OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE OTHER PERSON
WILL BE ELIMINATED
AND MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE PENTHOUSE
AND PACK YOUR BELONGINGS.
NICOLE, YOUR BODY IS BEAUTIFUL.
I STILL FEEL LIKE
YOU REALLY NEED TO WORK
ON YOUR FACIAL EXPRESSIONS,
ESPECIALLY YOUR EYES.
I FEEL LIKE WHATEVER WORRY
THAT YOU HAVE
COMES THROUGH IN YOUR PICTURES.
EBONY, I THINK
YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL.
THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN
IS SO BEAUTIFUL,
BUT THE TEXTURE OF YOUR SKIN
NEEDS A LOT OF WORK.
EBONY, CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, NICOLE.
♪♪♪
Nicole: I DON'T HAVE
ANY REGRETS.
I DON'T HAVE ANY REGRETS AT ALL.
THERE'S DEFINITELY A RELIEF
THAT I AM GOING HOME,
AND IT'S A SMALL ONE,
AND THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE
JUST TO BE WITH MY BOYFRIEND.
I GUESS I'M NOT GOING TO BE
THEIR NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪